so it's more in the area of like um
doing the
work and and just kind of like I don't
know when you said guys tend to over
complicate things and come up with [__]
I feel like that's maybe what I'm doing
what's the work that you need to do that
you're avoiding um I mean it's it's like
I don't know what I'm I know what I'm
doing or probably just [__] up on
[__] on progressing forward but it's
like I I'm doing things in my life um to
try and like you know become a better
person and stuff and it just like the
the one thing that I think thinking that
is like severely lacking like
career-wise
and like I am currently losing weight um
working out like four times a week and
stuff um which your height and weight
right now I'm at 510 255 and what did
you start out with when you got into uh
losing weight um earlier this year in
January I was about 284 okay that's a
pretty good Improvement um and like it's
just I like these past couple years I
was like kind of living underneath the
rock with just um chasing after like for
education and then doing like
internships I was like volunteering my
free time and so like just social wise
wasn't social up until this year and
um and because of that it's like you
like someone that completely know a
strict diet and then you start giving
them cookie dough and they just
completely you know and so
I think I socialize maybe too much um
and then in the summer like
our school district let me just stop you
here to sort of like get to get to the
meat and potato this I've got a magic
wand that I can wave right now to solve
your problem what is the problem what
does that look like probably finances
money yeah okay so what's your money
problem um like right now uh currently
like only for sure occupation I have is
like doing
ubering so you do what Uber Eats yeah
delivery how much does that pay you
monthly
I not sure just I just started doing it
a couple weeks ago and what were you
doing before that uh I was coaching at a
college coaching what um doing like
weight training and stuff weight
training coaching yeah and they just
like let everyone go in our department
without telling us how I mean you're
gonna have to forgive me here but I got
to point to the obvious because I know
that you know people in the comments are
asking but how are you in a position to
coach weight training if you're
overweight so this was like strength
conditioning so power like power yeah
for athletes is that what you do you do
power lifting yeah okay yeah I mean like
you'll end up with a big Burly physique
but that's not ideal I mean especially
as you get older and if you're not
professional you're not good at it like
what's the point in carrying the extra
fat right um okay so you've so I mean
you've gone and done like the easy thing
that everybody always does which which
like
I mean I hate to say it but like Lyft
Uber Uber
Eats it doesn't seem to pay a lot like
it it it seems to keep people pretty
freaking broke right like yeah how how
much you make in a week on average I
mean you got to have an idea of what
that looks like I don't know it's just
like each day I try to like get close to
like
120 and you've of course got your gas
and your uh you know like your repairs
and maintenance on a vehicle too but gas
is going to be your main expense unless
it's like like an electric vehicle did
you drive an electric vehicle or is it
gas gas it's gas okay so it's going to
cost you more to move around
like how old are you Dustin
34 if you could lean five years in the
future and paint a picture of the kind
of life that you want what does that
look
like
um more than financially stable and
acting acting what do you mean acting um
earlier like I've done some stuff this
year to become a better person it just
feels like in this one area it's since I
was let go and stuff I don't know just
it slowed down like I I have plenty of
things that I like to do um and earlier
in the summer towards the end of the
summer I did took some professional head
shots and then started sending them out
to like agencies where I live and I
signed with an agen
and um these past couple weeks I've been
taking acting
classes how's that going good it's just
it's something that I really uh really
enjoy and I think I'm decent at it from
the compliments that I've been getting
and stuff and it's where do you live uh
in
Arizona there's not much of a I mean is
there many opportunities for you to get
any jobs there for acting uh for like
commerci commercial Market there is
modeling stuff it's kind of they say I
think it's like script but I mean I mean
it's not the ideal place I think I think
Toronto probably has more films than
Arizona does I think I think Toronto and
U Vancouver probably has way more going
on um for stuff like that so you're in
the wrong Zone you know for starters
um what's your line of work like are you
a powerlifting coach or something like
what do you no so like I I have like a
degree in physical educ ation and then I
have a masters in
kinesiology okay so um like athletic
strength conditioning or athletic weight
train was like my
specialization it's just been like
extremely difficult to get into the
college uh sector where I initially
wanted to go yeah and then when you're
there it's like you're basically getting
paid teacher salary and work more hours
in a public school yeah like I mean
you've just figured out how not to make
money and get rich right yeah like you
legitimately do everything that they've
told the vast majority of the population
culture School Hollywood TV government
go out and get a job get your degrees
get your Masters and this and that and
you'll get paid fine and you'll get a
good job but you're stuck in a situation
now you're driving for Uber Eats right
um do you also do like uber and lift
like uh like taxi rides you know sort of
thing I don't do that is there is there
not a lot of like is there less money in
that than there is for Uber eat I'm not
sure I haven't tried the vehicle like I
drive like a Jeep looking vehicle okay
so I'm just not sure because I think
they're kind of strict on that for those
I think it's got to be a fordor like
2006 or newer or something like that I
don't I don't know what the rules are
but um yeah I mean dude like you've got
first I mean like you've the good news
is you're at the bottom so you got
nowhere to go but
up right so that's the good news right
like anything anything that improves
your life beyond you know where it is
today is going to be a significant
Improvement right you know if you get a
a commercial job if you get you know
something you know back in your field
that you've worked in in the past I mean
are you out there applying for jobs in
other schools or other you know places
where you got the opportunity to get
hired and do the same thing with uh
strength training yeah Kinesiology like
all the stuff that you been trained on
I've been applying um it just sucks be
in this position position because like
I'm doing other things like I've been
taking like country dance lessons um
acting
classes learning how to play the
electric
guitar um you know working out and
dirting so like I'm doing things on my
own to try and improve myself and
improve my value it just feels like this
aspect is kind of like anchored like
back there you know yeah I mean you
don't have a lot of confidence either
right I mean I can tell that your you
you know your demeanor and your general
postures is you don't seem to have a
very strong opinion of yourself and
where you're going right now right like
you'd like to be an actor
like have you read Arnold
Schwarzenegger's biography I haven't
have you read anybody's biography in
that area no it's just mostly the short
YouTube videos that they have so
his entire biography you know covers
life from Austria up to you know
becoming the governor and you know
beyond but he spends a good part of it
talking about how he got into movies and
the films and how hard he had to work to
do that right
um I think that you should spend some
time improving your mindset because
everything that you're doing today and
the results that you're getting is
coming from your beliefs and the choices
that you make right like the fact that
you're at the age that you're at right
now and you're struggling with money and
you got laid off and you're and you're
still overweight and you're looking for
I mean like your thing seems to be like
I want to get into acting like I want to
be on a screen like I can tell you've
got like a a very specific backdrop
there you know behind you with movies
and characters and figurines and all
that sort of stuff right like it's it's
your stick right like I get it yeah but
how are you going to stand out from the
crowd and and get hired for gigs like
this if you're down in you know down in
the dumps and down in yourself you're
not physically fit like like what role
will you
play shitty role is something comes up
that I don't
want like
why like why even start with a shitty
role in something that you don't want if
it you know if it comes
up yeah and I don't want that okay so
what would your idea role
be if you could have any role if your
casting agent could call you right now
and say I got it for you what is that
role I I told when I was taking myh
professional head shot and I was talking
the excitement came from saying that it
would be awesome if someday I was able
to be cast as like Freddy Krueger or
they in a hor roll or like James Bond
something like that
well there's no 255 pound 5 foot1 James
Bond Freddy Krueger or any of those
roles so first thing you got to do is
get yourself down to a healthy weight
which is going to be under 200 pounds
for your
height so start there because I mean if
you want to get cast in those rolls like
if that's what you want to do if you
don't want to do the shitty rolls and
you have to get
like you're on camera you know it's you
know the Optics of acting you know are
going to require that you that you look
a certain part you know a certain role
so start there if you want to get those
roles otherwise you're always going to
do just like the shitty things that you
don't like yeah it all starts here man
like everything here's like everything
that you get out of Life starts with
your belief system if you don't believe
that you're worthy of it I mean like I
ask you like you know what kind of role
you g to get you're like that's some
shitty role that I probably don't
want that's exactly what you're going to
get like that's what you're going to
attract into your life right so if your
belief system is calibrated and
coordinated in such a way that that it
makes good choices then the results that
come from those choices from your
beliefs will fully
align boom right so start with that get
your health in order I mean you need
money so you know do what you got to do
to make money but don't make [__] money
I mean don't Uber Eats is probably like
I don't know what it pays dude but I
know people that drive Uber and it's
like it doesn't pay that much so I can't
so I can't imagine that Uber Eats pays
any better no it doesn't it's just like
something like I gota let go and I was
like [__] and dude everybody everybody
when I hop into an Uber and I talk to
them like they sound exactly like you
they just like oh this [__] sucks I
have to do this because I need the money
and I got to eat and I got rent to pay
but I'm going to do it anyway it's
like now I've been filling out
applications fill it fill out
applications eat better do 200 push-ups
a day get out you know get your steps in
you know get your walks in get some
sunshine on you you know get the vitamin
D you know get your mood up read books
on you know successful people that are
doing things that you want to do right
you want to get an acting you you want
to get cast and I would start reading
you know biographies on people that you
admire you know start
there and question like I I've listened
to your book on
Audible and I'm listening to the
rational mail
about I can't I don't know how far I am
that's like the one benefit that doing
Uber Eats has been doing is like the
times that I am doing it for the hours
it's just clicking on your the
recommended videos of yours that pop up
yeah um and just all day pretty much
every day get Arnold Schwarzenegger's
biography and listen to the segment
specifically on how he got started on
his acting career
when you're driving then go and find the
next you know actor that you admire that
you know talks about how they got like
uh Matthew mccon did a book what's it
called green lights or red lights or
something like that I haven't listened
to it yet but I've heard it's fantastic
you know similar sort of timeline right
like find Icons that are doing what it
is that you want to do because
everything that you need to know is is
is in that piece of
literature forget about hypergamy and
solipsism and all that other [__] [__]
that for the time being okay you can
figure that out later no forget about
that [__] man forget about that market
no no no forget about that [__] you know
what you want to do start doing things
every single day that that that drive
you to the goal of what it is that you
want to do it's as simple as this Dustin
when you get up every day and you do
something and you have the opportunity
to sit down watch something drive
somewhere ask yourself is this going to
get me to where I want want to be right
like you have a clear picture of where
you want to be only do things that get
you to that
place as often as possible I mean
there's certain things that you know
you're going to have to depart from get
your grocery shopping you know make a
little bit of money here and there but
just about everything that you do from
the time that your head gets up from the
pillow to the time your head rests on
the pillow you your mind everything that
you're doing needs to align with where
you want to go and do that almost all of
the time with almost no exceptions
whatsoever get disciplined about it I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out